welcome to this video playing so cool
xoco what ever there's nothing more here
in the profile hmm okay let's do
something else modern defense no this is
this f3 setup is really very popular
let's play them played them very very
frequently here um some some time ago I
really thought about this opening
serious literature to incorporate them
into my repertoire and I really found
out that people play a free really
really often it's probably something to
do with them the popularity of f3 based
setups in them in the Sicilian where the
English attack and f3 against the dragon
is this very commonplace okay what
exactly is he doing him
not sure what 95 is all about I mean
okay before was some little bit it was
in the mix but still feels like a very
early night move
hmm okay
okay I'm always taking some time is
there something great that he can do
that I'm not seeing ok this move at
least does not indicate anything
anything great yeah maybe I should just
take it with the night with the bishop
p.m. yeah let's do that the bishop see
does not seem like a good attacking
piece anyway hmm i wonder if i should
castle here on not
no SG for coming definitely but it does
not look like I mean I probably have to
use my am yeah it's hard to play without
looks connected so I have to do this I
guess ya know something like this before
if he takes that rook p8 will really be
dangerous on the long diagonal yet here
thought b3 is the way to go if he takes
it night b3 is winning the Queen so I'm
really i'm getting lines open now this
is the the key thing so um what what am
i doing now 1c to our if I go if I take
on a three and on a two you will
probably play King a one check yeah the
setlist opens up the position reliably
and I have a discovered move with the
night is there a good square to go to 94
or something like that but from afar
it's not clear where I'm going
I don't see a great move 96 we will take
no well maybe to play 96 would love to
get the bishop here 96 night x is 6 look
see to night XD a droop takes you to him
no idea it looks funny maybe it imitates
them
he gets to see six at the end that could
be a problem now but I have to can take
on g4 it then okay oh yes to play your
night oops oops okay I thought he has to
play night xe6 check the team decides to
sacrifice instead this is a is it a
sacrifice King age eight if i take now
this is jay impossible yeah if i take it
this also Bishop c4 taken King cheeks oh
not really what I wanted all this Bishop
c4
yeah I really don't know what the what a
mess Bishop c4 d5 Bishop have six I can
take on c4 check
you should have six I take on see form
time body gem that this is equal
material funny enough I have to get to
the king that that's really clear let's
see
be three looks risky queen before
okay going to take this check look 25
ciao no check yeah this those bloody
pawns reserved wow this is really bad
run here so how did I screw it up I
don't really think that this shouldn't
be too bad but ok this is not Taurus
lemur him and so he allowed this and ok
this move wins yeah I didn't say I
didn't see anything in this game early
just just on this year oh my yeah so I
took it 96 takes here zetex here so key
the smooth now the comp just wants to
keep the material maybe I should have
done that I mean I saw it but like this
but it didn't look right to me brooksy
one or something yeah still it keeps the
material why not I mean why just has
given up material why not take it yeah i
don't know i have to head to play cloudy
f as I wasted lots of time earlier digs
this end ok now I cannot take on b2 it
seems this is this is already already
a.m.
already losing yeah this runs into this
I mean it didn't have much time but
still I should try to avoid it and I'm
probably lost anyway but still still it
wasn't bad and it was bad yeah because
this is so easy everybody will see it
ooh just bad just bad okay thanks for
watching